malik what are you saying about your
sleepy day
no no no there's this one story you told
me about where you uh
you couldn't get it up yeah i couldn't
and you you blamed it on
a a weed brownie or what happened you
know what i'm talking about now
is that i was like you suffer from
erectile dysfunction no no it was
homegirl was like aggressive with you
she was i was
i don't like when they two are me like
oh come on give me this give me this
[ __ ] give me this cop
i'm like oh give me that dick yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh that dick
come on [ __ ] i'm like oh wait time i
so i was like yo you know what let's
just talk first like so i was telling
her
like i was my two year anniversary i was
i was on the block right
i was having problems of staying i'm
with my ex big sean right
i'm with her and i'm like yo i can't
keep like i get it up but i can't keep
it up
and i'm telling my friends i'm 25. this
is this is three years ago right
so i'm talking i'm i'm like i go to the
block i'm telling my homies i'm like yo
listen
i can't get it up i need help bro i was
like man listen
don't you i can't go to my dad so i'm
like they was like yo listen don't worry
about that
you need a viagra pill but not any kind
of viagra pill i'm gonna take you to
7-eleven and get this black rhino oh no
she's gonna love you all that's that
john jones special
that's the job what do you mean what is
that that's like he got popped for that
he did we're using that yeah who goes
and uses those jon jones did
really yeah and obviously malik b let me
so dude
i didn't know i'm 25 they shot [ __ ] in
that there's like
dish soap yo it's a store it's the story
of behind
chinese guys sweat i did oh it is oh
yeah oh
it's all in there right so i didn't know
so i go to the 7-11 i get the pill
now my you our anniversary is tomorrow
right and i want to please her and every
time
um we get it up she like get up i just
like i have to fake an orgasm
gecko's limp yeah go limp i faked an
orgasm yeah i faked it
at 25. well because i don't know if i
wasn't attracted to her or something but
i don't know because you should she was
hot she was bad she was bad but you know
how like there's something going on
there
i don't know jake was like nah i'm good
but it's weird oh this is a different
story i was talking about the other one
let's keep going is a black
man so i took the black magic right but
they was like bro make sure you eat
so like mine you own i picked i picked
my ex
picked her up from work i'm talking cash
money [ __ ] too i'm like girl i hope you
got your handicaps on ready because you
ain't going to be here
yeah i'm talking because yeah she like
all excited like what got into you i'm
like girl that's that [ __ ] i'm like
what's about to get into you you know
what i mean i'm getting up with that
[ __ ]
right i'm giving her that good good
afternoon bro so i was like hold
on so she make dinner she's like babe
tonight's going tomorrow's our
anniversary
what'd she make for dinner she made fish
potatoes
and carrots i can't forget it that's a
lot of starch and i'm ready
that's a lot of energy okay i don't know
right okay
healthy i mean
we met in the gym so we try to live our
lifestyle okay yeah with some [ __ ]
so she made that
she made that so i'm like hold on babe i
go in the bathroom take the cause they
say you gotta take it after when your
stomach is on four you can't if it's
empty
is it 30 minutes before it's 30 well
something like that right
you need that blue chewable dude
twice as fast as the pill the tools
what else youtube.com all that [ __ ]
scares me
bro so i take the pill are we about to
have sex i don't feel it i don't feel no
it didn't it
was a while to kick in i didn't know
that so so i'm like god damn what's
going on
so i'm having sex the same thing so i
fake orgasm right
and she was like yo you came fast again
i'm like yeah i'm so sorry
but the next morning i'm on full solo
i'm a heart [ __ ] bro i'm so hard but
listen i'm so
hard i feel my heartbeat in my wrist
yeah you know what i mean like i was
like oh
and she's late for work i'm like girl
you better get your ass in his bed she
was like no
so i'm fully on hard now here's the
thing i have to go to the barber shop
i said a barber shop i didn't reschedule
that i know my barbershop was going out
of town and i need to get a haircut
so it was like it was a do or die
situation now you just do you tape it up
top and you know what it i tucked it in
so i'll walk you through them yeah tuck
them up top tuck them up top
come on the head exactly it should it
should touch your belly button
you put your dick it's uncomfortable put
the cover over your phone okay come on
it's uncomfortable but i went to the
barber middle school yeah
okay black barbershop it's packed that
day my appointment i'm i'm tucked up i'm
tucked in
i'm waiting i
[Applause]
untucked full salute it took one black
guy to say
this [ __ ] everybody started
they killed me yeah they lost me they
wrote hard
[Laughter]
my barber was like they was making jokes
imma give this cup but ain't gonna be
that hard i'm gonna go
damn bro they kill me just tell them
where you're like nah i took a pill
it was like you're taking the pill for
us you gave me that's what they went and
like not like checking
my channel like they used me as an ad
they was like hey bro listen i told you
gonna be looking good for me
dude and women look look how hard he is
for you like yo i swear to god the whole
barber shop lit me up
i've taken care of i've taken the cialis
before see what it's about and my doctor
sent to me
and then uh i saw the pill and one of
i my boys his name but one of my boys is
all dude yeah
i popped too dude so pop but his were
like small milligrams
my doctor gave me like the big boys if i
was gone bigger than him i'll pop two of
these but they're the highest
dosage you can get dude first of all
didn't this way need blue chew didn't
kick in fast enough
same thing me my girl have sex and then
i fall asleep
and i wake up to [ __ ] horror
bro y'all weird
it increases blood flow everywhere not
just your dick dude
my face was i was i was beat red
the veins in my neck were pulsating i
was sweating
my heart all that just to get the dick
to stay up never again
never again never again look here's
here's the symbolic of the story
later on tonight yeah is that symbolic
of the stuff i'll follow you
follow that okay look we're gonna try
we're gonna try okay he's trying to
follow you here's the thing
go ahead so after i get lit up i'm
talking about they lit me up in the
barbershop i get my hair cut
and i you know i like when black people
roast you i i turn religion sad i'm sad
i was like
bro like darling
so later on that night my girl's like yo
happy anniversary she gives me a wallet
and guess what she gives me a pill to
stay hard
i said girl go go ahead and cheat on me
i'll go ahead and say no more say that
no more big sean she said say less
wobble yeah but that was the first time
the second time was with this girl
uh jamie do you have uh
erectile dysfunction issues dude yeah do
you this is no because now now
i'm with my queen six figure queen um
i get up like man i don't i can't stop
getting up like we go all day i'm
talking we
like we like animals
before this girl she was just too
aggressive and i don't like that
man that turned me off like yeah did she
offer you candy or [ __ ] like she got
offered me like yeah listen that would
make me hard what
that means
i heard you like cadbury eggs
you know halloween around the corner
nasty
yo yeah so she offered me candy i was
like well hold on you know and i'm like
i don't really eat candy she was like
well come on i need
i need to get it like come on pull it
out she's not the candy was gonna entice
you yeah what are you
14. was it right was it right
now she tried to rape me i don't know i
don't know what she tried to do but
well and she was just too she was just
too aggressive i was like listen stop
stop yeah
and she was like what do you like women
i say yeah but not your kind of women
and she's like what do you mean you're
kind and you got into a whole discussion
i was like listen all right then she she
was flaming me and
roasting by the way yeah and she was
like yo i was like come on let's do it
and she was like okay we're kissing and
stuff like that and my you know how like
your penis no better than you
yeah i'm not getting he didn't get up i
was like what's sweet call her timeout
well i was like it's not you it's me she
was like you know what get your ass out
there's
nothing more embarrassing oh yeah she
kicked you out she keep me out there you
don't have any of those problems do you
no no erectile dysfunction chin you got
a problem with that
i've experienced it before yeah you know
i'm an older man i don't know i'll tell
you the story i think i told cat but
we have to keep it between us oh yeah i
remember that okay
between us yeah go yeah go don't worry
nobody's listening
so i did uh i took this thing
i know he said that like that's a
disclaimer you can't tell nobody
he does he does of the show
okay i'm
yeah so there's there was a girl that i
dated before yeah and then
you know what back then i used to party
a lot yeah party yeah it's a party so
i didn't know that cocaine let's just
say let's just say i took cocaine which
i'm not saying i did but i didn't know
it would affect your dick right yeah it
affects your dick
yeah so that you can't get it up right
no i mean it was like i couldn't [ __ ]
understand but it felt
really like a super horny but it felt
really good but i just couldn't get it
up
so then now i associated that whenever
we try to have sex again i associated
that time with her so i would have
trouble getting up with her came over
for a little while yeah cause if my
brain was associating that yeah
it was a mental thing oh yeah i think
it's just totally mental
blue balls no i don't know if i got blue
i was super horny
so i gotta say because you know you get
all riled up yeah you can't get it up
but you just got blue balls and [ __ ]
yeah but it's not working like your
brain well yeah once it didn't work
that's all i could think about i was so
freaking out you don't need to stop
taking stuff
but then i was back but then when you
wanna when you go to have sex it's so
stressful
exactly that's all you're thinking about
and that's the worst come on dude that's
it
like i get in the bathroom i slapped him
right yeah
yep i talked to him i was like listen
we've been together
all our lives yeah exactly what are
y'all doing to y'all ding-a-ling
bro i'll slap his ass up
he'll get a real beat down and perform
like michael jackson's dad i'll beat the
[ __ ]
you ain't gonna perform i beat the [ __ ]
up i didn't get it up and
i put these dick beaters on him man hell
yeah yeah y'all crazy yeah bro you're
crazy
[ __ ] you your hand turned that shake
weight in your mind you better get your
yeah
yeah yeah oh i'm sorry chappelle never
had any dick problems
i mean i didn't know people just
naturally had dick problems yeah why
why thinks the way people buy viagra and
[ __ ] blue chew man the business is so
crazy
first of all this just scares me because
the like it gets your heart rate like i
you know i got high blood pressure yeah
yeah yeah i don't [ __ ] around you know
that's why it's illegal like in
sports you can't take vaga or bluetooth
because it does increase your
cardiovascular that's what i'm saying
that's actually
an illegal substance yeah i don't like
to take anything [ __ ] nyquil freaks
me out
you know microsoft i just see that
girl's terrible thing that's [ __ ] like
that girl's so bad for you
it's not yeah are you ever taking it you
have you taken it before when i have
headaches
you take it for a headache that's
something you want to take nyquil for
yeah that girl's nasty
yeah you know you don't mess with
anything huh no i mean
like i said i'll smoke a joint i'm on
all sorts of that yeah nicotine
kratom you have a little drug try it
vitamin d
vitamin d vitamin d yeah vitamin d uh
well yeah it's in like my multivitamin
but oh i do like the
fiber forty percent yeah dude this is a
blue chewy check it out
forty percent of men by age forty
struggle with
uh erectile dysfunction how crazy is
that 40 percent well they need to judge
it off based on when you lost your
virginity
right i don't think when i get off stage
at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son